kasachstan brennt und nun fordert der
flächenbrand im neuntgrößten land der
welt offenbar todesopfer das behaupte
das innenministerium das von putin
freund nursultan nasarbajew geführten
landes demnach sollen mindestens acht
polizisten und soldaten der
nationalgarde getötet worden sein um den
protest der regimekritiker blutig
niederzuschlagen hat die diktatoren
klicke jetzt das militär losgelassen
fallschirmjäger haben sich mit
demonstranten kämpfe geliefert die
aufständischen nannte präsident casino
mart pokale terroristische banden
berichte aus der größten stadt des
landes al mahdi zeichnen ein anderes
bild regime kräfte schossen demnach auf
demonstranten laut krankenhäusern wurden
53 zivilisten verletzt oppositionelle
nachrichtenquellen sprechen bis zur
ausschaltung des internets am
mittwochnachmittag von vier toten
protestlern
der 68-jährige total hat jetzt
machthaber wladimir putin um hilfe
gebeten vor allem in der metropole an
marty der diktatorisch geführten
republik hatte es schwere zusammenstöße
zwischen demonstranten und
sicherheitskräften gegeben
videos und bilder zeigen die polizisten
mit blendgranaten und knüppeln gegen die
menge vor gehen autos und häuser
brannten darunter der präsidentenpalast
in kasachstan kommt es seit dem
vergangenen wochenende zu protesten
auslöser waren zu nächst höhere
gaspreise an tankstellen inzwischen hat
sich die landesweite protestwelle jedoch
zu einer blutigen revolution gegen
langzeit diktator nursultan nasarbajew
und seine clique ausgeweitet